hey guys my name is Nigel young and this
is my wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
I've seen a few videos
wired autocomplete yeah Uncle Roger seed
the Ouija before he likes some
Millennial pool you just Google yourself
hi yeah
[Music]
who is Uncle Roger
hello niece and nephew eat me I cook
food and talk [ __ ] why does Uncle Roger
love MSG of course I love MSG it's the
king of flavor it makes everything
better if you can't cook just sprinkle
MSG on it your pasta instantly get
better put it in everything if your
marriage is not working sprinkle MSG on
your marriage your wife's Not Gonna
Leave You Why does Uncle Roger hate
Jamie Oliver hi yeah Jamie Oliver [ __ ]
up all the Asian food have you seen his
egg fire rice he put chili jam on it egg
fried rice three ingredient egg fry and
rice and you still mess it up Jamie hi
uh why does Uncle Roger say hi yeah
that's just a slang word it just means
you're disappointed in something when
things don't go your way just say higher
you stab your toe High yeah your baby
born with three arms hi uh Jamie Oliver
make egg fire rice
what is uncle cool Rogers nationality
Uncle Roger from Malaysia you remember
the two planes that go missing that
where I'm from
of course that went and corrected to
YouTube now change of career what is
Uncle Rogers
phone number I cannot give you every
particular stock calling me all the
thirsty Auntie gonna start calling me
cannot what happened to Uncle Roger
what happened to me I still here nothing
happened nothing happened
where is Uncle Roger from Malaysia I say
already
how to basic
Uncle Roger Uncle Roger reviewed this
YouTube channel how to basic this guy
just opened 20 packets of instant Noodle
and tried to flush it down toilet so
many people dying of hunger and then how
to basic just just go watch it I don't
want to think about it how to make ramen
Uncle Roger Ramen very difficult to make
so don't try at home just go eat at
Ramen Shop if you can go to Japan that
even better don't make ramen at home you
end up making just some terrible miso
paste in boiling water type Ramen that's
not good proper Ramen you need like 12
hour 18 hour 24 hours just to make the
broth so don't even try just go out and
eat how does Uncle Roger make rice I use
rice cooker do you have that if you
Asian you definitely need rice cooker if
you white try to buy a rice cooker
because I see how white people make rice
is the saddest thing they use saucepan
they eat that Uncle Ben instant
microwave Rice [ __ ] hi yeah while
your rice come from pouch it's the
saddest thing
Uncle Roger favorite chef of course a
Gordon Ramsay for you cotton make food
so good he make egg fried rice so good
uncle Roger orange Polo okay this is my
Polo nice color it fit my complexion
this is a nephew if you want to buy this
Polo I got much go to Uncle
rogermatch.com I know Wyatt he they're
going to delete out this part they're
not gonna let me plop my merch but don't
delete this [ __ ] wired I gotta watch
this video I gotta complain Uncle Roger
adobo oh Uncle Roger recently reviewed
Food Network adobo Jeffrey Zakarian he
[ __ ] up a topo he put parsley in it
parsley in Asian food you ever have that
that I putting Sriracha in pasta hi yeah
yes what is Nigel UNG famous for I
played this character called Uncle Roger
his middle age kermatian Uncle who just
complains about everything and uh I blew
up making a BBC food egg fried rice
video because they really messed up egg
fried rice such a simple dish that every
Asian knows how to do in in our sleep
for the BBC you know this this great
world-renowned organization they can
report on like Pearl Harbor at World War
II and all those things like amazing
journalism but they can't make a simple
Asian dish when did Nigel young start
comedy I started a comedy in 2011 when I
was in university I went to Northwestern
near Chicago as Open Mic at a coffee
shop we just went on stage nobody was
listening people just on their laptops
and I got a few Chuckles my first gig
that gave me enough delusion for me to
keep going do you prefer doing stand-up
comedy or do you like making YouTube
videos as Uncle Roger oh they're both
great they're both great in different
ways Santa we get the immediate rush of
the audience's laughter YouTube you got
to just film it at home you don't have
to leave you just film it you Dropbox it
to your editor the edits you edit you
post it everything's good you don't even
have to leave the house so it's great
bring on another pandemic I'll keep
making the YouTube videos who is Nigel
UNG dating uh no one right now
[Laughter]
oh God I feel so thirsty can Nigel UNG
actually cook I am a decent home cook if
it's from scratch then it's usually just
something simple like pasta it's
annoying to cook for yourself because
you go to the grocery store and then you
have to buy like a whole bulb of garlic
and then I'm not gonna use like four
cloves that's it you know and then you
just you just end up wasting a lot of
food so I end up just eating out a lot I
think too if you if you're bad at
cooking the trick is not to continue
cooking you know because you just keep
repeating the same mistakes over and
over again if you're bad at cooking stop
cooking go eat out you know stop being
cheap just spend your money at a
restaurant
foreign
have an accent yeah a little bit right I
think that's it's a mishmash of
everywhere I've lived a bit of UK a bit
of America a bit of Malaysia people meet
me and then they assume I have an accent
and I have to tell them no there's just
a character I don't actually sound like
that but if you live in the Western
World sometimes it's it's hard to be
understood if you have a really thick
accent especially on dating apps I
probably miss out on a lot of matches
because they look at my Instagram and
then they're like oh [ __ ] I don't want
to go out with this guy who sounds Super
Fresh Off The Boat some people do have a
stronger Asian accent there's nothing
bad about that but this is what I sound
like pretty normal I think that's Nigel
UNG speak Chinese
I can't be saying anything right now and
then why it won't even know I could be
talking [ __ ] about them how many times
have been you you make make it make it
what channel that's Nigel on have a twin
no but a lot of people confuse me for
the emotional damage guys even he we
have two different Asian people okay
how much is Nigel UNG worth oh I don't
know not as much as you think I don't
have a boat yet let's put it that way if
you search me online they think I'm
worth like a few million like man I wish
you guys really think very highly of me
every YouTuber just get a few
subscribers and it out comes the Bugatti
I'm like how do these people afford this
you know and then they all live in the
same YouTube house are they just renting
it is it a rental I can't afford a fancy
car
uh just a Tesla Model 3 you know the
cheapest Tesla
how is Nigel on
I'm good thanks
how tall is Nigel young I think I'm five
foot nine and a half but I rounded up to
say 5 10. that's okay right give me the
extra centimeter I know a lot of guys
just put six foot on their dating
profiles and then what do you expect is
going to happen the woman's gonna show
up and then what you're gonna charm your
way to two extra inches like come on man
just just be honest how to pronounce
Nigel aung Nigel Ong
when did Nigel aung move to the UK 2015
for a woman and we're not together
anymore so I'm stuck there now
Nigel um data scientist yes before I
went full-time comedy I was a data
scientist I was doing that at the
daytime and then I would just go off and
do my shows at night and then repeat
that for like four or five years it was
exhausting big reason why the marriage
didn't work out you know
is Nigel unfunny I hope so a lot of
people have come to my shows and they
enjoy it so far it's just search Uncle
Roger Tour on Nigel Young tour maybe
I'll be performing at a city near you
so how do you feel about your Google
searches it's pretty good we're all
pretty tame nobody searching Uncle Roger
bad stuff Uncle Roger quite happy about
that
foreign